hello everyone I'm Dana Perino along
with Judge Jeanine Pirro Harold Ford Jr
Jesse Waters and Greg Gutfeld five
o'clock in New York City and this is the
five
[Music]
America's biggest city is being
destroyed by Biden's border crisis
that's a stunning statement not coming
from Jesse Waters but from Liberal New
York city mayor Eric Adams he says the
streets of the Big Apple are completely
overrun by illegal immigrants with over
10 000 migrants arriving each month
I don't see an ending to this
this issue
will destroy New York City
destroy New York City we're getting 10
000 migrants a month
every community in this city is going to
be impacted the city we knew
we're about to lose
Eric Adams is frustrated with the zero
support he's getting from the Biden
Administration but looks like he wants
to have it both ways by also pointing a
finger at Texas
go item for item on what Eric Adams ran
on as a candidate and then look at what
we've accomplished in 20 months
we turned this city around in 20 months
and then what happened
started with a Madman down in Texas
decided he wanted to bust people up to
New York City
and the first day of school here in New
York City and the classrooms are swamped
with some 21
000 non-english-speaking migrant
children and the Biden Department of
Education says it's on the schools to
find teachers that can communicate with
all of them the cover of the post
summing this up as a kick in the ID
which if you're British that sounds very
good okay so
Adams wanted Jesse to not blame Biden
directly he wanted to sort of like the
indirect blame and sort of wants the
Republicans to have to take the blame at
the same time but he's so unwilling to
say that the root cause problem that
Biden won't deal with is the reason he's
almost there the message is clear Joe
Biden's going to see that and that was
probably the most passionate I've ever
seen a politician all year never seen
that kind of emotion that was like a
call to Arms a cry for help all at the
same time and it's clear when you drive
into the city or you walk around we're
overwhelmed you now have sidewalks you
can't walk past because they are stuffed
full of Migrant families it looks like a
foreign capital in certain sections of
this city you don't recognize the city
anymore it's just not what you're used
to they're not New Yorkers they're not
even tourists they're from third world
countries and they're not assimilating a
lot of them are not working and there is
a crime issue we had a guy who was
arrested like seven times from Venezuela
assaulting people he's a basket case we
do not have a grip on the situation and
it's going to cost the city a fortune
because you're giving everybody free
stuff they get free education they get
free health care and they get free
syringes they get free room and board
they get free food thank God it's
culturally appropriate meals but the
guys tried everything he tried Randall's
Island and then he tried putting up at
five stars in Midtown
and then he tried shipping them Upstate
to Buffalo
and nothing is working and you'd think
Schumer had a little more juice because
he's the senior senator he's the Senate
Majority Leader he can't get on the
phone with the president and say
something's got to give here Mr
President
this city is beyond repair because I
agree there's no stopping this no and
Greg I'm wondering if this debate could
end up making the situation work because
one of the things that mayor the mayor
here and the governor of Massachusetts
had said is we need more money to spend
on this and we need faster work permits
and the root cause is that people think
there is work here so if there's a
promise of a work permit then they're
not going to stop coming across the
southern border yes we're incentivizing
this and I agree with Jesse that's
probably uh uh mayor Adams that's the
most passionate I've seen a politician
this year since I hooked up with Nancy
mace but
Greg
[Laughter]
I'm kidding come on it's the five so I
I realized why I was a liberal in high
school and I was a liberal in high
school I was a liberal for about a year
or two in college because liberal ideas
are amazing and they're beautiful they
really are you have to admit that their
goals their ideas of sanctuary cities
for for example Sanctuary cities is
wonderfully altruistic and they're easy
to talk about right as long as you never
do them they were actually impossible so
that's why they are on bumper stickers
and that's why they are on t-shirts and
that's why they're when they're
implemented you have misery and the
reason why they don't work is because an
idea is not possible without a system
and thanks to the tough love of the Mad
Men of Texas we married the system to
the results and what you saw was a
collapse of an altruistic liberal idea
and we know we know this if you're if
you're if you're an adult you have a
family and kids you understand that
goals liberal goals without conservative
systems are inherently destructive
because they offer rewards without
consequences as you say the incentives
of jobs and Welfare and free education
life is very simple there is no free
lunch in anything you do anything you do
everything has a cost even the good
things Elite Democrats in the Upper West
Side in SoHo they have the luxury of
beliefs without the consequences as it
ruined the border states that they
rarely visited right so they sponged off
these people for decades and now the
madman the madman which I believe the
Mad Men are us because they got the idea
from us we were the ones that were
saying marry the policies to the
consequences if we just do that you will
change the country and right now it's
going rock bottom but the only way to
get back is Rock Bottom it's going to
change the country we have to do the
exact same thing this busing thing with
crime there has to be some very brave
people very brave uh police
Commissioners and sheriffs who will get
the people and drive them to where the
D.A lives if you're going to release
them after you book them why not just
get them in the van and you drop them
off on the streets where the DA's live
marry the consequences to the policies
one of the things judges that we were
talking about mayor Adams being
passionate but I want you to get the
call for ready because he was also
passionate before and it's fine you can
change your mind but you should really
be honest about that let's watch this
here
when you think about it the days I spent
with our essential employees a
substantial number of them were
undocumented they were delivering our
ubereats they were stocking our stores
they were out in the streets keeping our
city running we have to expand NYC care
to make sure everyone has health care we
need to make sure we have proper
translation services in our schools
that was then this is now you know what
it's actually humorous and I I mean it
sarcastically this is a guy who talked
the talk and didn't walk the walk this
is the guy who today has to put his
money where his mouth is this is a guy
who today is passionate why because New
Yorkers are fed up in all the five
boroughs they are going crazy on Staten
Island they are going crazy with people
who are uh have businesses near hotels
that have more than 50 percent illegals
the people who are now in in in places
that were historic places that are being
changed so that we can put illegals in
this guy was going to put illegals in
schools so kids couldn't have gym
classes I mean yeah he's passionate he
doesn't want to lose his job but I tell
you I am furious about the fact that he
wants to blame Governor Abbott as if
Governor Abbott is not also an elected
American official suffering from the
same negative policies that have
destroyed his state for two years this
guy gets a couple months of it Lord
can't take it I can't take it if you
can't take it then go after Joe Biden if
you can't take it then you call Joe
Biden a Madman you don't call Greg
Abbott a madman and I'll tell you
something else everyone in New York City
is paying a price to live here we're
losing businesses there's a mass exit
Exodus because of what's happened to the
city and I resent the fact that he says
I turn this city around no you didn't
this city is devolving further and
further the crime is horrible we just
heard about a 60 year old woman who was
hit with her own cane 50 times the
police let the guy go you know mayor
roll up your sleeves and start dealing
with reality and stop talking Harold I
think you agree with this statement that
a problem ignores ignored becomes one
that gets harder to solve down the road
every time and then you'll have people
in Staten Island and elsewhere getting
so mad so it's making it more difficult
and I'm thinking that Joe Biden is
determined to lose on this issue and
it's the very one that helped Donald
Trump win the first time
you're right he came down he escalator
and made those comments I'd say a couple
things
um we oftentimes talk about identity
politics and we talked a little bit
about it yesterday I wish some of our
politicians Democrats a lot of
Republicans some are most of identify as
a problem solver we have a serious set
of issues happening on our border the
idea that we allow and I think what it
boils down to uh judge we allow Asylum
Seekers to stay here while their
application is being reviewed for
whether or not they should be able to
leave home we probably need to stop that
they're going to be those that may be
critical of those who may share my
opinion and suggest that it might be
racially motivated
race can be a factor in in how we think
about a problem and how we solve it but
it it shouldn't infringe upon us or
impose Upon Us negatively as we think
about solving the problem just because
some person of color or some person
who's not of color is affected by it
what mayor Adams spoke to was a reality
here in New York we don't have the
resources to deal with this Challenge
and in fact the resources that we are
allocating towards a challenge could be
allocated towards mental health issues
could be allocated toward helping
alleviate the homelessness challenge in
our in our community and could actually
be allocated to helping to deal with the
public education or education challenges
we have in our Public Schools instead
we're having to deal with this and judge
I I don't I don't I don't think this is
a Democratic Republic Mission we look
back over this it's been both parties of
the blame however where you're right the
president has a responsibility we don't
have a coherent policy on our border and
if it was a Republican president we
Democrats would be saying you get us a
policy and I think it behooves all of us
as Americans regardless of our political
stripes to say we need an answer to this
and I think mayor Adams Jesse I think
you're right this is the first time I've
seen him is passionate and as emotional
as he was in this issue here and he said
words I never thought I'd hear from this
mayor this could destroy New York City
he was the most positive person running
one of the most positive running for for
mayor and for him to say this I think
it's a wake-up call not only for
Democrats and the president but for New
York uh and for all of us around the
country about how and why we need to
address this problem more seriously Dana
yes do you know what time it is it's
time to to destroy Harold Ford all right
oh Harold I know that you believe in
many laudable things it's why I would
vote for you for president I think you
say to everything you say here makes
total and complete sense doesn't it
frustrate you or mystify you that all of
these goals that you have are rarely met
or destroyed because your party refuses
to work with the other side you
mentioned all of these things like the
homeless programs which we were all four
who was in charge of that where did that
go look I'm asking you to diagnose what
is going on in the Democratic party that
refuses to create a process or a system
that would lead towards a goal that's
all I'm asking so you mean what you
really mean is with president with the
white house because there are a number
of Democrats including the mayor here
and some other Democrats On the Border
who are saying we should deal with this
differently I think a lot of it Greg has
to do with the investment and
unfortunate attachment we have to
Identity politics I think there may be
some in my party who wrongly believe
falsely believe that this how this issue
somehow another is going to Advantage
Democrats if they don't deal with it in
the way that someone suggesting that you
may want to deal with it more
aggressively than me but one thing we
can agree on we've got to deal with this
and again identify as a problem solver
and give us some answers to this is all
I ask in your face
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling and now analysis you will not
get it anywhere else